so I don't know the question when do I
consume my apple cider vinegar drink so
let me just create a short video on that
a lot of people like to do it at their
meals which is totally fine personally I
like to do it in the morning sometimes
I'll do it at a meal sometimes I'll do
in the morning sometimes I'll do both
but in the morning I'll do about 16
ounces of water okay two teaspoons of
apple cider vinegar I use Bragg's you
could pretty much use any try to do
organic if you can and then two
teaspoons of lemon trying to do organic
lemon juice and sometimes they'll do a
turning a little bit of sea salt okay
and I'll dissolve that in there simply
because when you're on a low
carbohydrate diet you're gonna dump a
lot of water you're not going to have
the volume of water that you had before
which could trigger low blood pressure
if you don't have enough volume of fluid
because it's the salt that holds the
volume plus the lack of sodium because
you do lose electrolytes on the
ketogenic diet could create some muscle
weakness as well and what's called keto
flu all this could be remedied by a
little bit of salt you basically need a
little more salt when you're doing a kid
out like one teaspoon a day okay if
you're doing a high carbohydrate diet
you don't want to do even that much okay
because you're gonna retain fluid and
this and keto caused you to lose the
fluid okay so this is the drink that I
like to consume so the opposite of
vinegar will help the digestion helps
blood sugars it helps reduce hunger and
cravings if you have that it's a great
transition tool as you're doing keto
adaptation into fat burning the lemon is
really good to prevent kidney stones
that the type of stones that are more
common with the ketogenic diet is the
uric acid stones okay because your acid
does go up a little bit when you're on
keto but this is really related to pH so
in other words if you keep your pH a
little bit higher you're not going to
get this uric acid so if you have strips
you can measure your urine you want to
keep it six to six point five maybe even
six point eight that's perfect you don't
necessarily want it five if you have a
predisposition
position two kidney stones or gout okay
just a little tip there and the way that
you would handle that is you could the
lemon juice helps and also what helps is
potassium citrate which is an alkalizer
and all the vegetables that you're
consuming another way to slightly raise
the pH to make it slightly more öcalan
is to add the raw wheatgrass juice
powder to it and a little shaker bottle
shake it up some people mix both of them
together so there's different ways to
handle the pH if you're concerned about
having higher levels of uric acid which
doesn't really happen in a lot of people
but it can't happen this is actually
more common when you have high carbs
because look at it diabetic there their
risk factor for uric acid and your uric
acid stones and other types of stones is
really really high so anyway when you
take it you take it in the morning or
with meals thanks for watching so we've
been getting a lot of success stories
but I don't have your success story yet
so click the link down below and upload
you before and after I want to actually
hear about your success story I want to
see your before-and-afters and every
week we do featured success stories so
click the link down below and share your
success